europe is going through another summer
of record-breaking temperatures the
north is bracing for a week of extreme
heat while the south is already
experiencing temperatures climbing to
new highs hundreds have died from the
effects of the extreme heat strong winds
are fueling destructive wildfires across
a number of nations
several firefighters have been killed
it's burning in france
spain
in portugal
italy
and in greece
for a week wildfires have raged across
southern europe
several firefighters have died in the
line of duty and thousands of residents
have had to flee their homes
it is an especially difficult summer
we are dealing with very considerable
drought due to insufficient rainfall
over the winter and spring
and especially dry months of may and we
now have particularly high temperatures
but there's another related threat
sweeping the region a heat wave that has
already claimed hundreds of lives
temperatures have reached the mid 40s
for a week in some parts of southern
europe
and weather experts say it's moving
north to a place that's never before
experienced heat like this
the united kingdom
forecasters are predicting temperatures
of 40 degrees in england where few homes
can cope with these conditions
experts are warning
that thousands could die
this is serious heat
that could actually ultimately end in
people's death because it is so
ferocious and we're just not set up for
that sort of heat in this country
but authorities say there are steps
people can take to protect themselves
drink plenty of water
stay out of the sun
and check on those at risk
we can now hear from scott duncan a
meteorologist in london hello scott even
higher temperatures are expected next
week in parts of europe why is this
happening
indeed as you've just seen from your
footage there that we've had intense
heat down in the south western parts of
europe so mainly spain and portugal and
also north west africa but that is
basically going to start lifting its way
north over this weekend and into early
next week and there's a few factors
behind it as mentioned also in that
report it's been exceptionally dry so
the ground is very very dry and very
easy to burn but that's also good for
transporting the heat and then also
maintaining its intensity all the way to
places like northern france and even
into places like northern england and
all the way up to scotland for example
so we've got basically a perfect weather
pattern for delivering this heat but
also the surface conditions are just
primed to break those records
as we said even higher temperatures are
expected in the coming days are the
forest fires that are happening likely
to continue through summer
yeah we do get wildfires quite regularly
across the mediterranean especially
throughout summer but we've seen in a
trend in increasing intensity and more
kind of widespread nature of these fires
especially in the last few decades
um so yeah places that experience these
high temperatures are more likely to dry
out vegetation is easier and faster to
burn it's not the heat that obviously
triggers the fires themselves but
basically when we do get ignition
whether it's man-made or by natural
causes then it is something that will
then burn faster and harder and that's
what we're seeing across not just the
mediterranean but now spreading into
places further north i wouldn't be
surprised if we saw more wildfires even
on the british isles for example
talking about spreading to places are
the record temperatures just hitting
europe or is it a worldwide
issue so this very intense heat episode
for western europe is is probably the
most intense currently but we've been
seeing uh several events throughout not
just this year but the last few years in
particular would be breaking record
breaking records not by just small
margins but by enormous margins and it's
not
confined to just europe like last year
for example in canada the
record-breaking heat dome there we've
also had intense heat in japan over the
last couple of months which was
shattering long-standing and very
significant record so it's not just
europe we're seeing a lot of heat
records tumble across the world we are
seeing cooler weather for example in the
southern hemisphere it is a la nina uh
condition at the moment so australia has
been seeing record rainfall it's been
quite cold there also new zealand for
example but the the main emphasis is
that there are far greater number of
heat records falling compared to any of
these localized cold records and this is
all part of anthropogenic climate change
so
why are people finding it so difficult
to cope
so places like the uk
for example or northern france so far
away from the mediterranean we just
don't have the same infrastructure as
those places that typically get well
into the 40s for example so a 40 degree
heat is not the same here like in london
than it would be in the south of spain
like the buildings that we live in just
don't cool down the same they're not
built with the heat in mind
places down in the mediterranean are far
more equipped and they build literally
everything from not just the houses but
the roads the rail everything the
infrastructure is built to withstand
that heat only about 0.5 of houses in
this country have air conditioning which
is a tiny amount so basically it doesn't
have access to
the respite that we need
thanks for that explanation scott duncan
meteorologist in london
and in sweltering berlin delegations
from around 40 countries have convened
to confront the climate crisis german
chancellor olaf schultz and egyptian
president abdel fattah assisi are set to
address the forum known as the
petersburg climate dialogue it's meant
to set the stage for the bigger climate
conference the united nations cop 27
taking place in egypt in november
on monday german foreign minister anne
elena berbach said countries need to
redouble their efforts to hit climate
targets
all of us from the pacific island to the
sahel to europe know
climate
is the most important challenge of our
time
because it threatens the lives of
millions of people it threatens our
peace and stability order worldwide
it is the most serious international
security issue of our time
dw political correspondent nina haza is
at the german foreign ministry where
that meeting is taking place and nina
just tell us you know the host country
itself germany what is it doing to
tackle the crime crisis and is it seen
as enough
well that's precisely the point some
countries are now beginning to say
germany is not doing enough and that is
of course against the backdrop of
russia's war against ukraine because
germany like many other countries is now
frantically looking for short-term
solutions because germany is very
heavily dependent on russian energy
supplies and so the government had set
out to be one that is going to step up
the fight against the climate crisis but
now is potentially seeing a lack of
energy supply because of its dependency
on russian energy so the chancellor is
traveling around the world trying to get
short-term supply solutions for example
in senegal in may he said that germany
would potentially be open to support
senegal in terms of gas explorations
germany has also announced that it's
going to extend its coal power plants
and that is something that the
government had already announced
would be phased out eventually so many
people are questioning whether the era
of fossil fuels really is over and of
course some people especially in the
global south are saying if germany is
not
doing everything it can to put
everything into renewables how can they
expect us to do it so there's a lot of
mistrust here
coming from the global south towards
countries uh in the richer north also
including germany and against that
backdrop nina what are the concrete aims
of this meeting in particular
and can we expect to see any progress
well it is the first time that this
dialogue is actually being held in the
foreign office so analina berber the
foreign minister from the greens has
made it very clear that she sees the
fight against the climate crisis as the
biggest crisis in terms of international
security because of all its implications
on other areas on refugees on migration
etc so this is something where she says
it is vital that uh
all the ministers have to get a get
together to prepare the next big climate
conference in november so that they can
put pressure on each other so that more
can be done two political correspondent
nina haza thank you